hello again you're watching Al Jazeera
we've got some breaking news coming out
of turkey and Syria places that are
still reeling from two devastating
earthquakes another earthquake has just
struck near antacia the 6.4 magnitude
Quake shook buildings and was felt as
far away as Beirut let's immediately go
to our correspondent who's in gazientep
in Turkey Assad big Assad you also felt
this Quake tell us all about it
well you were about to go live in fact
just just over half an hour ago we felt
the floor move the ground move we saw
people running we're next to a petrol
station the staff immediately ran out
there's some police standing down the
road again they again ran for some cover
the building behind us that has been
cordoned off already part of it uh
destroyed because of the the first two
earthquakes it began to shake the
chandeliers inside because see them
shaking and then we began to hear
reports of this earthquake now we
believe that it originated in Hattie
around 6.4 on the Richter Scale we're
also hearing reports of some destroyed
buildings uh but unconfirmed at this
point in time but there have been
thousands of aftershocks now this is a
first earthquake after those two initial
ones uh initial earthquakes two weeks
ago and we have to remember there's been
a considerable amount of Destruction uh
thousands of people dead but also there
are still buildings that are standing
but have been damaged now the fear is
that if there are heavy aftershocks or
earthquake in fact like this it could
bring down those buildings that have
been damaged causing even further uh
damage to the area or even threat to
life now when this earthquake took place
just over half an hour ago we had one of
our producers here in gaziantep airport
now he said that the entire Airport
Shook and people began to run it created
a sense of panic we have someone else in
hata airport and that airport was
evacuated so there's still this
considerable fear uh among people of
possible strong aftershocks but this
earthquake definitely will really scare
people we've been speaking to people all
week and they've been talking about the
psychological impact of those
earthquakes and the sense of security
that has been destroyed and the
authorities here will be concerned about
those damaged buildings and probably you
know widening the quarter and as we've
seen the police moving around here
thinking about widening the coordinate
around some of those damaged buildings
where are people who have lost their
homes in the first earthquakes two weeks
ago Sheltering is there anywhere that's
actually safe as you say we're
experiencing aftershocks almost daily
so the many people inside uh tent cities
uh so in Open Spaces like football
stadiums uh so there's been tent cities
set up but people have been moved out of
the earthquake zone now the president
Richard type erdogan was speaking
earlier on today and he said over 300
000 people have been moved out of the
earthquake zone so they've been put up
in University dormitories uh State guest
houses uh hotels uh that are outside the
Zone but there are still some people
inside these cities intense cities but
others I've seen uh refuse to move from
outside of their building because they
still have belongings in there and some
are still waiting for the bodies of
their loved ones to be bought out so
what they've done is set up a tent
outside their building uh that was
either damaged or destroyed they have a
fire going to keep themselves warm but
those people will be under immediate
risk if those buildings are to collapse
so it varies in terms of where people
have even has now Richard type erdogan
said that 1.6 million people have found
temporary accommodation but there are
still many people within cities like
gaziantep like Caravan like hatai that
are still in those cities within the
earthquake zone and again it will be
reliving that trauma going that sense of
fear especially when we've just had a
strong earthquake a 6.4 and this comes
just a few hours after president erdogan
was in this region making his second
visit to the affected areas he was
making some big promises wasn't he to
rebuild within a year I mean those
promises seem a bit fake really almost a
bit distant when you're still getting
aftershocks that are damaging further
buildings
absolutely it is a huge and massive task
ahead of him he said give me at least
one year and he said that they will
rebuild but they have to remove that
Rubble they have to bring down the
damaged buildings and start from scratch
and he also said that they uh won't have
any buildings higher than four stories
higher now he's asked people to give him
at least one year he's he's also said
that there will be financial help for
those affected in terms of destroyed
Apartments there'll be money given to
people to help them with rent they'll be
money given to people to help them move
but he's he has a year
there is an election plan there was an
election plan for me and if you speak to
some people this considerable anger at
the government in terms of how was this
allowed to happen why did so many
buildings collapse now we don't know if
those elections will take place but if
you speak to some people they believe
he's asking for a year to not only
rebuild confidence in the state but also
to rebuild uh his popularity amongst the
people
okay Assad baig joining us there from
gazientep who felt the the 6.4
earthquake that shook the area just
within the last hour let's speak now to
zaina hudder because she's joining us
from Beirut that's another area where
this earthquake was felt zaina first of
all just tell us what you experienced
there in the capital of Lebanon
well the Tremor was quite strong and it
lasted up to 15 seconds people here are
terrified many of them are now in the
streets people across Lebanon really
felt those those Tremors initial reports
suggest that what they felt was a five
magnitude earthquake this was what they
felt here now two weeks ago following
that major earthquake on February the
6th in central turkey
buildings here shook so it was very
similar to what happened back then and
the trauma the anxiety is still fresh in
people's minds and many are are
concerned because a lot of the buildings
across the country really are not
structurally sound many of them are old
dating back to the days of the Civil War
damaged and
worry because successive governments
have really not done anything to enforce
standards building building standards so
people are in the streets they're
concerned and this is a country which
has you know seen its share of disasters
two and a half years ago there was a
massive explosion at the Port of Beirut
that trauma still as well fresh in the
minds of the people here in recent in
recent days the government
um
uh carried out inspections in the in the
north of the country and the singled out
hundreds of buildings in in the city of
Tripoli uh which were not structurally
sound so that those that that Tremor was
felt it was a strong Tremor people are
terrified and many are now in the
streets
and zaina you've been speaking to people
in Northern Syria again an area that was
devastated by those twin earthquakes two
weeks ago the death toll standing at
over 5 000 people there many thousands
more homeless an area that's proving
very very difficult to get to uh with
Aid and help but tell us what people
there have been telling you in the wake
of this recent earthquake that happened
just in the past hour
yes we are hearing um from our contacts
on the ground that some buildings have
have collapsed in Two Towns genderes
um and salkin John Davis was among the
hardest hit towns during the February
6th earthquake so some of the those
buildings have now collapsed and we're
also getting reports that five people
have been injured in another town atarib
that's also in in the north of the
country a very vulnerable region many of
the buildings um were damaged during the
course of the 12-year War not
structurally sound and even very poor
building standards uh so the majority of
the people are now living in tents no
doubt they left those buildings that
were damaged but this is going to create
even more fear and anxiety to a
population which is just struggling to
survive 4 million people live in this
corner of Syria it's controlled by the
opposition two million cannot survive
without Aid and that was before the
February 6 earthquake eight has begun to
arrive but there has been no really
coordinated International response
unlike in government-controlled areas
you talk to doctors in hospitals and
they tell you that we are overwhelmed we
cannot treat the injured we have many
Crush injuries which means we need to
provide kidney dialysis sessions to more
patients because Quest injuries are
could have fatal consequences yet they
don't have the necessary equipment to do
so they're talking about bandages they
lack bandages they lack doctors so there
there's an emergency in hospital there's
an emergency in in intense cities where
you know people have lost their
livelihoods eight thousand ten thousand
people in all of Syria were injured
eight eight thousand a little bit over 8
000 in in the opposition controlled
North so all these people need treatment
need care so now with this new Tremor a
new earthquake more buildings collapsing
more injuries this is just going to
cause uh more suffering to to a people
who have been used to years of death
destruction and displacement
Zayna with that many people needing
access what is happening on the
international front to try to negotiate
access to these areas through Damascus
well the Syrian president Bashar
al-assad a few days ago approved
cross-line deliveries which means that
the International Community of the
United Nations will be able to deliver
aid from government-controlled areas
into opposition-controlled areas now the
opposition was alarmed by this what they
were saying was they don't want to be
hostages yet again of a regime that they
do not consider legitimate they believe
that Bashar Assad was trying to exploit
uh the The Tragedy by controlling the
entry points or controlling what Aid
reaches the people what the opposition
wanted was for the International
Community to bring aid from from um from
Turkey through cross-border deliveries a
few days later the Syrian president did
give his approval to open two more
Crossings apart from the Babel Hawa
Crossing which has been used by the
United Nations for for a few years now
but as we all know Southern turkey has
been devastated a lot of the aid
agencies
they were trying to pick up the pieces
that themselves so this is not going to
be an easy task for Aid to reach uh the
the northern part of Syria but most of
the aid has been arriving at
government-controlled airports in
Damascus in in Aleppo so it's a legit a
logistical nightmare really for Aid
agencies to reach the people in the
northwest corner of Syria ice people who
are isolated people who who are really
relying on the support of turkey which
today needs international support
following uh the devastating the
devastating earthquakes and the biggest
concern now among people in Northwest
Syria is not just about surviving it's
not just about getting food and and
Medical Aid they are seeing a man the
president of Syria who they accuse of or
who was responsible for tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of deaths slowly inching his way back on
the international stage
um it has just been reported that he is
an all man visiting a second Arab
country a year back he was in the United
Arab Emirates so Arab countries are now
opening up to re-engaging uh with with
Bashar al-assad so these people are not
just worry worried about survival
they're worried about the politics what
what will their fate be if the if if the
Arab world or or part of the
International Community we engage with
Bashar al-assad without resolving their
faith because they cannot and will not
live under his rule so as you can
imagine all all these uh problems
compounded after years and years of
conflict and and and and crisis after
crisis
okay zaina thanks very much indeed
brings the latest from Beirut these are
pictures just to remind you if you're
just joining us from hat Thai in Turkey
also seeing pictures from Adana in
southern turkey where a major 6.4
earthquake has just shaken the region an
earthquake that was felt across Southern
turkey as well as Syria Lebanon and
Egypt no reports of further casualties
yet but there have been reports of
further damage to buildings that have
already been devastated by the two
earthquakes two weeks ago we'll be
keeping across this and coming back to
it later in the show